mr president ladies gentlemen
dear friends the great huntsman mandela has
said things in life that
always seem impossible until they are
done i could not describe better the
performance of the founding fathers of
the european union or not  which
I have the honor to address you this
morning our union the european union was
born of the will of those who returned from the
battlefields and screens of
concentration in 1945 were able to make this
eternal prize is  after war
never again war a reality by
opposing both the force of arms
the force of law and the rejection of
others solidarity with others
the primary vocation of our
European union remains and will remain to be a
work of peace whose  action must
extend far beyond the borders
of Europe and because we have a
burning obligation to
assume the responsibilities which are
ours in the world, we must be
present in the world and because the
planet belongs to all and not
just to a few and
every people has the right to the same
dignity multilateralism is and will remain the
guideline of our action in the
world
there is no lateral ism or
happy protectionism the world
needs openness to cooperation the
rules and principles to resolve
conflicts to eradicate poverty to
reduce inequalities to develop
fair and free trade
job creators and new opportunities for
all to preserve our planet which is
part of it  indivisible
of all humanity the
common rules consent and freely to
each of us do not hinder us
on the contrary it frees us from the law
of the strongest and makes each of
us stronger and we should better
respect our institutions
multilaterals which it is true are
not perfect but this is not a
reason to put them back in the race
or to withdraw from them on the contrary  re it is
a call for the mobilization of all
energies for reforms and
modernizing them to give them a new
breath when we have to do it for
the united nations
centerpiece tss multilateralism
guarantor of peace and world order
and we  put antonio guterres knows that he
can count on the full support of
the european union to carry out the
reform that he is carrying for an
organization whose functioning
and ambitions are adapted to our world
of the 21st century and tomorrow  as
today
the european union will continue to take
its share of responsibility in
achieving the major objectives of
this organization which is more than
ever essential to us,
i am thinking in particular of the implementation
of the united nations program for
sustainable development in the  horizon 2030
the development of which we have
largely contributed and which requires the
mobilization of all our policies
and all our financial means
ch  dear friends it is for me a
unique privilege a lasting inspiration
to have met my bible these words
continue to resonate in me even
today he came from a continent the
cousin continent young noble
promising a future this africa with the  europe and
bound by a community of
destiny what our neighbors have said with whom we
want to forge ever closer ties
because a law an alliance between our
two continents an alliance between equals
and the only way possible because our
efforts  spouses depends on the fate of
millions of men, women and children
I believe, Mr. President, that
today the greatest tribute
we can pay to Madiba
is to follow her path to the future and
to hope, an avenue  towards the
permanent dialogue of continents and
civilizations towards the inseparable freedom
of a globalized human family
love of others thank you for
your attention